gibt es ihn oder gibt es ihn nicht einen
riesigen planeten der sich um unsere
sonne dreht planet neun gemeinden abo
physikerinnen und physiker sind sich
einig dass er irgendwo da draußen in
unserem sonnensystem existieren muss
doch einen direkten nachweis bleiben sie
uns bislang schuldig nun haben spanische
wissenschafterinnen und wissenschaft
nach handfesten beweise für seine
existenz vorgelegt welche das sind und
wann wir den mit seriösen
riesenplaneten wohl endlich zu gewicht
bekommen werden jetzt in science fiction
herzlich willkommen
es ist schon fast ein bisschen peinlich
für die abfuhr physiker und
physikerinnen von heute achtung weiter
antike konnten sie tatsächlich nur zwei
weitere planeten in unserem sonnensystem
dingfest machen und das trotz der
großen technischen fortschritte in den
letzten 100 jahren die entdeckung der
sogenannten planet 9
von dessen existenz die meisten
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
überzeugt wäre somit ein riesiger
durchbruch im bereich der astrophysik
der rose wettstreit um einen möglichen
neuen planeten unsere songs sind ist der
bereits vor jahrzehnten entbrannt
forscherteam weltweit jagen das phantom
und jeder werden verschiedene
anhaltspunkte für planet 9 haben
forscher sind bereits gesammelt mal mehr
mal weniger stichhaltig dadurch ist ein
relativ konkretes bild von diesem
mysteriösen riesenplaneten der wie es
wohl irgendwo in unserem sonnensystem
versteckt hält entstanden weiß nicht 9
handelt es sich nach meinung vieler
astrophysikerin und physiker entweder um
einen gesteinsplaneten mit dem
vierfachen er durchmesser und einer
masse die maximal zehn mal so groß ist
wie die der erde ein gigantischer
brocken also um es mal auf den punkt zu
bringen berechnungen legen nahe dass er
wohl 10 bis 20 tausend jahre braucht um
die sonne in einer langgezogenen
umlaufbahn zu umrunden
beim nachbarn zur sonne setzen vorstadt
dienst um etwa 20 mal größer ein als
den abstand der sonne zum planeten
neptun mathematische berechnungen eines
forscherteams aus madrid haben nun
weitere und bessere beweise für planet
9 gebracht dafür analysierten wie die
outfits der sogenannten ethnos darin
extrem franz neptunus objekte also kunst
neue himmelskörper also die
ausgeprägte exzentrischen also
langgestreckte umlaufbahn um die sonne
kreisen minden aber jenseits der bahn
des äußersten gasplaneten neptun
dabei machten sie eine überraschende
entdeckung alle der bislang 28 bekannten
ethnos werden genau wie 24 weitere
aktien im weitläufigen umlaufbahn
beeinflusst durch eine schwere bislang
noch nicht identifizierte masse
diese sei wohl verantwortlich für die
signifikante abweichung in den umlauf
waren der eu
mutmaßten spanische forscher teams noch
mal auf den punkt zu bringen ein planet
also der etwa 300 bis 400 astronomische
einheiten von den untersuchten e-plus
entfernten muss wechselwirkt mit ihnen
unsere ursache ihrer charakteristischen
umlaufbahn merkmale planet neuen lässt
grüßen dieses ergebnis stützt
tatsächlich auch die analyse der
bislang wichtigsten forschungsarbeit zu
dem gigantischen brocken noch im
vergangenen jahr hatten
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
aus den usa gemeinsamkeiten in den orbit
sechs verschiedener ethnos entdeckt
beispielsweise zeigten ihre messungen
dass die längsachse der elliptischen
umlaufbahn ungefähr in dieselbe
himmelsrichtung zeigten ein erstes ernst
zu nehmen sie für planet 9 und für
eine gravitationskraft wir auf andere
planeten ausübt und andere
himmelskörper
doch es gibt auch astronom und
astronomen die trotz diverser hinweise
nicht von der existenz eines neunten
planeten ausgehen ihr argument die
bislang bekannten eigenschaften - seien
nicht repräsentativ und somit auch
nicht dieser ausgezogenen rückschlüsse
auf platz neun
denn selbst große teleskope seien
heutzutage noch nicht in der lage
transaktion diese objekte in ihrem
extremen umlaufbahn zu identifizieren
deswegen sei die existenz weiterer
ethnos denkbar deren eigenschaften in
keine rückschlüsse auf planet neuen
zuließen
doch der großteil der fortschritt
lässt der bahnpläne 9 nicht los denn
es gibt einfach so viele messungen
berechnungen die übereinstimmend auf
seine existenz hinweisen trotzdem ganz
schwierig kleinen nächster zeit zu
entdecken zwei probleme stehen dem weg
zum einen ist der bereich in dem sich
dieser mit der löwe planet versteckt
hält viel zu groß und zum anderen
existiert in diesem gebiet nur sehr
wenig sonnenlicht diese beiden faktoren
machen die suche nach planeten
tatsächlich zur der suche nach der
berühmten nadel im heuhaufen so läuft
die fahndung nach planeten weiterhin auf
hochtouren und es bleibt dabei seine
entdeckung wäre eine wahnsinnige
sensation und könnte uns ganz neue
einblicke in die entstehung und
evolution unseres sonnensystems liefern
jeweiligen werdet ihr mit als erste
erfahren planet neuen entdeckt wird wenn
ihr kein video zum thema und auch zu
allen anderen themen verpassen wollt
dann durch mehr ihr ein abo aufsaugen
und vergesse ich den
auf die glocke hier geht es weiter mit
wird ein planet unsere erde zerstören
da geht es um den mysteriösen planeten
nibiru spannendes video natürlich also
nicht verpassen
draufklicken und viel spaß dabei und
ansonsten bis dahin bleibt